now while Hunter wants to use the Second
Amendment in his defense his dad's
Administration is looking to make it
more inconvenient for lawful gun owners
in this country back in January the ATF
put in place a rule targeting something
called a pistol brace that's an
attachment that lets you fire your gun
one-handed basically a stabilizer and it
was actually designed for the disabled
the rule would reclassify Pistols that
use the brace as short-barreled rifles
and if you have one you need to register
for a federal license and if you don't
then you face get this up to 10 years in
prison and up to a ten thousand dollar
fine
this is what we're talking about this
piece of plastic and I'm holding it here
but I won't be holding it on June 1st
because I'll be a felon so this is this
is the big threat that's the big threat
to America is a piece of plastic
so that rule was supposed to go into
effect today and as you heard
Congressman Matthew say you could be
considered a felon if you didn't
register the brace but late last night
hours before the grace period for the
rule was ending a federal judge in Texas
temporarily blocked it in response to a
lawsuit from gun right activists joining
me now is Georgia Congressman Andrew
Clyde he introduced a resolution trying
to block what he says is an
unconstitutional move by the ATF
Congressman that's a minor win but
what's next isn't this just a backdoor
push to impose a federal gun registry on
millions of legal gun owners well thank
you Rachel great to be with you tonight
I will tell you this is Extreme
government overreach by the Bureau of
Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms that's what
this is plain and simple they're
redefining a rule redefining a
definition to make stabilizer brace
pistols into short barrel rifles and the
amnesty period ended last night but
fortunately we did have a couple of wins
in the court one was by Gun Owners of
America last night and one was about a
week ahead of time ahead of that but um
but we're still fighting this because
those lawsuits only cover just a few
people
this entire issue is affecting Millions
upon millions of American citizens
including those with disabilities a
service disabled veterans all of them
unless they have removed their brace or
registered their brace with the ATF and
some states don't allow registration of
short billed rifles so in those States
they don't even get to keep them but
they will become felons overnight as
last night so today you had better not
have a pistol and unregistered pistol
with a stabilizing brace on it or you
will be a felon again like you said ten
thousand dollars excuse me ten years in
jail and actually a 250 000 fine
so do you think that maybe this latest
law is it getting around to all the gun
owners is this a maybe something that
might Galvanize gun owners to start
directing more of their energy towards
gun rights because you know the NRA is
kind of weakened these days
well I'll tell you that this is an issue
that every gun owner should be concerned
about and we in Congress should be
concerned about it too I introduced h.j
res44 with 190 co-sponsors on it it is a
bill that needs to come to the floor I
was told by a leader scalise on Tuesday
afternoon that it will come to the floor
next week I'm a little concerned because
I saw the rules notice and it's not
there so I I'm hoping that our
Republican leadership is taking this
seriously enough because this does
affect Millions upon millions of
Americans law-abiding Americans who
overnight become felons because of the
ATF overreach here so this is a a
serious very very serious issue that we
in Congress have to take seriously but
the federal judge has blocked this at
this time but again this is an issue
that will affect disabled Americans who
are losing their right to defend
themselves Congressman thank you for
joining us this evening hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else